Melanie is in Georgia hi Melanie welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show Oh
I recently resigned from corporate
America to get out of the rat race and
follow God's purpose for my life and to
figure out what the rest of my life
should look like we're a family of four
I'm married my husband is disabled and
we have two small children preteen
teenager my corporate job was like 85 to
90% of our income so now we're living
off his disability check which is like
twenty two thousand a year in child
support as well we have no debt so when
I was working we were on baby step six
we have no debt except the mortgage
which is like 66 thousand but now that
we're living off my husband's check
we're back to baby step one because
we've used up our emergency fund but we
do have a long-term savings which we
pull from to supplement the disability
check so I'm just kind of in a position
where I I don't like to do because we
believe in the steps and we were doing
the steps we were almost baby step seven
but now we're kind of back to start one
okay so what is your career plan well
the career that I was in I resigned from
corporate America because I knew that
wasn't where I belonged so right now
what I'm doing is is I have the freedom
and the time if I didn't have the
freedom and time before but now I have
freedom and time to really speak out
God's purpose for me and follow like
what my gifts and my passions are I
don't necessary have a career plan right
now it's more of like just building my
relationship with God and figuring out
who he called me to be and what he
called me to do or whether it be
preaching teaching now I have the
freedom to figure that out if that makes
sense okay well I completely agree with
your goal of finding God's purpose I I'm
not sure I agree with your process for
getting to your goal because your
family's starving to death and that's
not me but I mean that's not God's
purpose for you right exactly
neither does
take care of his own household is worse
than an unbeliever right no we've
applied for such things are not
completely starving but we did apply for
food stamps and you're gonna call that
God's purpose that you walked out of an
$85,000 your job and now you're on food
stamps and that's God's purpose no it's
not even close no no no I'm just talking
about me not being in the rat race for
the next 50 years of my life I didn't
want you to stay in the wrong I said I
agreed with your goals I just don't
agree with how you're getting to them
because you've left your family
vulnerable so you got about 30 seconds
to get some income coming in okay while
you're searching for God's purpose okay
working while you search for God's
purpose is possible now possible you
were in a toxic environment with 80
hours a week and they weren't you know
they were devaluing you as a human and
you're a rat in a wheel and you needed
to get out of there I don't have any
argument with that walking out cold
without a plan is not biblical so I want
you to I want you to develop a plan here
where you know 24 hour day meditation is
not feeding your family and you have the
ability to create an $80,000 year income
we know that you were doing it before
now I'm not suggesting you go back to a
toxic environment that's not what I'm
saying and I'm not saying you need to
abandon searching for God's purpose for
your life I want everyone to find that
I'm blessed in that I have found it but
along the way you feed your family that
is also God's purpose for your life okay
and so your family starving and you have
this fabulous ability to earn a living
what were you doing before um
training communications marketing a lot
of media work and I've been helping my
husband because he's an entrepreneur so
I have been using my gifts to help his
business I'm he's a speaker author
entrepreneur and then I've also been
looking into photography like taking
photography classes to generate income
it possibly that way so I have been
using my gifts while I'm off work but
you're not making any money all right
I'm not generating income but I am need
to generate some income because you
listen you're articulate you're bright
you're a great teacher communicator
trainer you ought to be able do
something for a
while even if it's not you know maybe
Paul making tents you know what I'm
talking about
what that I remember when the Apostle
Paul made tents in the bible in the
bible he I don't think that I know that
okay all right well long before he was
the Apostle Paul after he met God he was
on the backside of the desert looking
for God's purpose and he was a tent
maker he made a living he meant living
as a tent maker while he was waiting and
later we know him as the writer of most
of the New Testament but but in the
meantime he didn't starve
he worked while he was war I was
searching for God's purpose and made
money while he was searching for God's
purpose and so I think that's the part
that I'm missing in your story that I
want to as gently and kindly as I can I
don't don't want you to hear me
rebuking where you're going it's just
how you're getting there because you are
so valuable in the marketplace you're
worth 60 to 120 thousand dollars a year
in the marketplace you have proven that
yeah yeah and your family needs you to
be worth that yeah I agree I want to
generate income I just don't want to do
it the way I was doing it I don't
disagree with that but you need to get
with it you know and that's what I'm
trying I guess what I'm trying to figure
out how what that and you you you don't
have long they don't your own food
stamps when you have the ability like
yeah they Billy make 85 grand you're on
food stamps so I mean Tom's up go make
some money doing something even if it's
not the exact perfect thing you think it
has to be you're not gonna find this
perfect thing by the way where you go oh
that's it that's it that's the whole
thing it never is there's always parts
of everything you do this side of heaven
that are unfun fun I've got the best
life in the world there's parts of what
I do is unfun everyday so I get to do
this show which is three hours of fun
everyday and that's God's payback for
some of the crap I have to do this so
you know you just you need to go make
some money kiddo in a way that is not
the old way but it's not the perfect
utopian new way you've dialed up in your
mind and um you know but and you can
find God's purpose on that so I'm gonna
send you a copy of Ken Coleman's book I
think it'll help you a lot it's called
the proximity principle and I will help
you on this journey but I want you to
get back to making some money and
tete-a-tete a for your family there's
just that that is a process while you're
looking for his purpose that's what you
need to do because it's just it's a
shame that that you're not making money
because you have the ability to you're
just a bright lady and you can do all
these things so hold on we'll send you a
copy of that